[Music]
good morning Dancing with the Stars fans
I am Lauren Zima unfortunately our own
Cameron Mathison isn't here today but
luckily I got two guys for the price of
one Alan Burstyn and qiyamat Cephei are
here oh my gosh I can't even imagine how
tired you guys probably are what a
finale last night you lost your voice a
little bit from what just cheering I'm
very quickly in the moments we've been
sitting here sensed kind of a loving
brother Levi between you two a little
bit of a bigger brotherly vibe they're
both in pain many people don't know this
but I actually knew Kiel before I even
joined the show we did a show together
called burn the floor okay yeah and so
we were touring the world we did
Australia Japan actually liked him so
much
yeah who's Messier Oh probably me yeah
when you live together you tour with
someone you know a lot about that well
on the bus you know we're pretty clean
on the bus we're pretty minimal okay I'm
good I just bring a lot of shoes yeah I
would have thought you'd be more into
fashion than Alan what about the fact
that last night was the Dancing with the
Stars finale and you guys I'm sure have
questions and comments for these
handsome gentlemen so leave them on our
social media pages and I will get them
here on the iPad and we're gonna dive in
because you guys a lot of people are
actually talking about this finale in a
way I didn't think they would because of
the fact that the second place was not
distinctively announced it's just two
runners like did you guys know that was
gonna happen
yeah we did it was such a short finale
there was only an hour there wasn't
enough time to make it third place
second place in first place and also in
England in the Strictly Come Dancing
they only do first place as well
interesting all right well massive
spoiler alert though it's been ours if
you guys didn't know Adam and Jenna took
home the Mirrorball trophy there they
are and the runners-up were Sharna and
Josh and
say you knew who second place I mean did
that do you think that that you know ate
the runners-up today I don't think it's
because in the finale you just want to
celebrate you know it doesn't matter who
got second or third ultimately it
matters who wins or who made the finale
I still I think also they said it
[ __ ] they also want to know like did
I come third or second like what did
that go you know well we added up it was
kind of a wild mathematical equation as
well because we had points we had votes
I think voting open live kind of towards
the end we added up just the points of
the night and it was so close Adam and
Jenna with 58 Sharna and Josh with 57
Tanya and Sasha with 56 I mean one right
after the other did you guys think that
Adam and Jenna are going to take it home
uh yeah I think throughout the whole
season he was really strong week one his
personality was amazing yeah like he was
so funny
off camera on camera is such a lovable
person so you were rooting for him even
though you're competing against it yeah
and Tanya what a journey I mean I mean
she surprised us all also I kind of
thought like Tonya was gonna take it
reason being because I was like has
story from week one and every week and
then from there like her last dance
because I was in the freestyle I mean
yeah so like a celebration she's getting
a second chance in life and I was like
this so off she went for it see that
those turns right do you want to talk
about woman who can do a triple axel and
she translated it onto the dance floor
but I want to ask you guys that's the
thing is you just said Tania's journey
and of course we've been with you from
rehearsals from the beginning talking
about this is a short journey it's such
a short competition overall what's the
sense from the pros how do you guys feel
about this really shortened competition
would you ever want to see I mean it was
quick it was quick it was fun it was a
lot of a lot of action happening I
prefer the long seasons just because you
really get to go on the journey with
upon the celebrity with each other and
America gets to learn about each of us
you know in this four-week season the
packages were shorter you didn't really
get to learn a lot you didn't see a lot
of growth you just saw the first week a
lot of people did improve
and there was a lot of impressive
dancing happening but you didn't really
see like the struggle because they
didn't have time to show it
yeah well and it was interesting too
because so often the competition the
athletes are the ones who shine so I
almost wondered if they were all you
know so good and then you really didn't
see that change because they were pretty
good from the start and then you just
saw those little improvements I mean
yeah there was in every season the
athlete is always someone who's so in
tune with their body they know that if
you just tell them to adjust this
they'll be able to adjust it it's a
quick adjustment right whereas other
celebrities might not be as quick here
everyone was so quick but also I think I
was also at least though like my foot
obviously the season working with Jenny
also like you have to tell them exactly
what to do like well you have someone
like an actor like Jody for example like
I'll teach her the core graffiti to the
dance whatever and then she can put her
own flavor in it that's good I know I
think what's it with with athletes like
in a longest season you can break that
in you can break that in I think this
train so for so long in one aspect
that's why Adam did maybe have that edge
because he kind of already has that
personality and he already was putting
his own flourish on things so you felt
like the athletes were very to the point
versus bringing in that oh yeah I got a
point which Janie asked me she goes so
how do I smile I said ask Allen kids I
don't know yeah well yeah Cameron
Mathison who again isn't here but he's
not here I know but he was there last
night so check out his interviews on
Entertainment Tonight
tonight's from behind the scenes and
backstage but he said that he feels like
remembering when he was on the
competition that week four is really
when you start to fall in love with
people and you break through and so did
you sense that like oh this is the week
where he would have broken through but
now it's anything was that you know I
feel like actually week three is when
they started I mean although it was so
quick I think the most the best week in
the season is usually most memorable
year just because that's when the
celebrities tell their stories and here
we did Most Valuable Player which are a
person because it's similar again
everyone
got into where they are from one person
either pushing them or from the
motivation from them so it was nice to
see who inspired these athletes yeah and
this season I feel like a week 3 when we
did that that's what really opened up to
America and how they really learn about
the celebrities yeah well I was on the
American Idol finale red carpet right
after Dancing with the Stars
um but Ryan Seacrest had said that he
also wished you know he wanted Idol to
have a little bit long so it was a crazy
year I think week's comments coming in
Jessica says on Facebook that she feels
like Sharna got robbed
I do want a mirror ball for that I
wonder how unbearable we all one mirror
before the funny thing about the season
is I feel like everyone kind of got
robbed you know yeah Jamie and Johnny
they got eliminated the first day they
didn't have any chance to grow like
every week it felt like it was someone
got robbed especially a good yeah
because especially on because you don't
usually have eliminations on that first
week yeah and I was surprised I thought
he reminded me of oh gosh uh Murray and
his name David from you know from the
cut I thought I felt like he would have
had that same arc a family man a sports
guy and he really was sent home on week
one yeah it was a lot about the dancing
this season it was yeah do you think
more so because it was short because
these athletes are so into week two we
had two dances I think you had a you had
one chance to impress America yeah so I
know when I was choreographing it was as
many as you can go hard yeah everything
yeah take the shirts off Jennifer on
Facebook says that she thinks Josh
should have won the mirror ball so well
Shauna and Josh by the points anyway
we're in second place but Edward is so
happy that Adam and Jenna won I think
you know any of those three couples I
mean honestly I feel like it could have
been anyone honestly everyone earned
that yeah everyone who made the finals
deserved it and it was just who America
like more yeah do you guys feel in some
way that these talented athletes were I
don't know if wasted is the right word
but like it's like didn't you just want
a longer season with these people yeah
because the growth out of like all the
celebrities this season I think
amazing bike for my partner Jenny for
example you know kids like grown to be
like an amazing dancer right because it
was so quick it's likely she's throwing
everything for them right I'm like do
this split do this leg up and be like I
can do that like with six well Jade on
facebook says Keo and Ellen you both
really stepped up your choreography this
season great job I mean thank you
I guess I looked at it as a plus but
tell me if I'm reading into too much it
kind of felt like this season
maybe the newer pros were really
invested in a little bit more because
you know some of the older pros weren't
here and newer pros like Jenna and um
people hadn't had as many seasons really
got some amazing partners I think yeah I
think it was um
you know just because athletes everyone
was so good I feel like but it was it
was an opportunity for people to really
showcase their choreography and I feel
like everyone did a really good job this
season Lindsay that was crops to her did
you guys see this as an opportunity for
America and for the viewers to get to
know you a little bit better again
because some of those I don't you know I
think they got to know Isis like you
know personality-wise because I think it
was more focused on the celebrities I
think my instil I've really showed them
I mean yeah I think um the tour's is
where that's when really good I know us
yet yeah just because you know they run
into us on the street we talked to them
we're really nice see them on tour yeah
I don't know what our next tourism um so
do you guys have any idea what those
final scores are like we said you know
last night we're not gonna find out who
was in second and third but throughout
the season after the episode do you ever
find out like what where anybody was
there no like we have around we don't do
run with our executive producer really
you should tell us because then some
people will work harder yeah but just to
me I just always like to feel like
I need a work the hardest no matter what
even if I'm at the top because what if
you're at the top you're like oh I'm at
the top I can relax this no you want to
work even more I feel like it's good
that we don't know okay I also like I
think like last before the finale
a week before three couples went home
yeah I was definitely fourth place
that's clear everybody was number one in
our hearts Bobby says the people who got
robbed were the American people this
season was too short
well I mean you always want to leave
them wanting more yes what a Tom
Bergeron
what about any fun behind-the-scenes
stories or secrets that you guys can
share with us from the finale you were
in Tanya and Sasha's number how was it
pulling that all off with her coming
down from the ceiling I mean there was
there was I think seeing her during like
rehearsals and camera blocking and dress
rehearsals it was so different I always
go toyou know she's like she goes up and
their eyes are closed and then like live
show because I was seeing also like
where I can see her she was like eyes
were wide open I was like okay no she's
more comfortable now you know but like I
think like I said like her stories from
week one into like the finale and like
every star was more like a celebration
so I kind of enjoyed that more because
then also what dancing is all about
dancing the Stars about like big numbers
like that
yeah like a celebration at the end you
know so you know it's it's funny how
dress rehearsal which is an hour and a
half before the live show is so
different than the live show even
waiting for us like every every week you
know when there's a lot when you know
you're live and when there's a thousand
people in there watching you dance
differently yeah you know it's either
it's literally make it or break it some
people crack under the pressure and some
people thrive off of it yes so you
either feed off that energy
oh yeah but you hopefully it be feed off
that everything yeah but integrating
this season for me and Mariah and even
Jenna and Adam we didn't get Sunday
camera blocking so Monday was the first
time we both got to do it on stage with
our partners Wow so like because they
were traveling cuz they were
they had their stars on ice too so every
Monday was the first time we ever did it
and it was like really scary
dressers was still scary and then by the
show it came together so do you guys go
all out in dress rehearsal to see how it
is yeah I wondered if maybe you're
afraid like energy or something that
people don't really know about me yeah
okay
well um Lia on YouTube says Allen you
and Mirai were amazing I think you
should have been in the finale and gene
on Facebook said I really loved the fact
that the newer pros got a chance to
shine and I'm sure someone now needs to
say the key Oh should have been in the
fuse man so that he feels good about it
thank you a lot of you were a lot of
people saying the season should have
been longer yeah guys agree I'm the mix
the fall season's come the fall season
is coming up will be good also want to
ask you guys about Dancing with the
Stars junior will you be involved in
that speaking of more Dancing with the
Stars
when is that supposed to start I it airs
the Sunday before our Monday okay every
week there's two dancing in the stars
days two different shows which is really
cool as if you guys don't need more work
to do you know but I I think they're
grateful very good yeah I think they're
awesome actually because it is two
different types of shows we don't really
know how the juniors is gonna work out
yeah you know I think it'll be cued
though I love kids so I kind of wait
yeah we haven't been told anything or
even how it's gonna work but I just
think it's gonna be really awesome to
have two different nights of two
different shows but we're still dancing
yeah for the kids and one so you might
be involved I mean oh you're probably
gonna be involved oh I know he last time
we talked you're dating somebody are we
talking about Dancing with the Stars but
you said you were even then you were
like I really want his do you pressure
guys Johnny and I'm getting hot
you're single I'm saying why are you
single by the way why you look good bro
you look amazing there's so many lenses
again I would say it's cuz of my
personality no yeah I have no idea I
don't know I do I'm single
are you dating anybody at all no I'd
single single but I mean well you can be
dating but be it like on the record
single are you asking people out is it
because you're busy with work you know I
am a little I have been busy okay going
on tour and then on the show
I don't know how Q managed to find you
make time brother you make time you mix
the crisis juice I call my mom too much
[Laughter]
yeah I'm you know what though those
Dancing with the Stars show manses I
mean last night Jenna winning and Val
being so supportive of her he kept
flying out to see her I mean I know that
you're dating somebody who's not a
dancer but let's make a prediction now
do you see yourself winding up with a
fellow dancer you know I don't know what
do you think okay I'll say whatever
happens happens
have you dated a fellow dancer before
[Laughter]
and how did that go
I know it's funny you're always with the
person so and you work together does
that mean that you get really close
really quickly really casually there's a
thing for me like I applaud people who
are dating and like work together
I know it's hard I kind because like
going on being on the show together
going on the tour together it's staying
home together like I need the brave
doesn't get any time for himself no not
that I just need a break to get home in
like you know go in the kitchen and cook
and talk about something different like
you know I mean you know what I think
it's nice to date someone in a different
field because you talk about yes when
you're with each other every day what do
you talk about you know you experience
this together there's a lot of talk
about that ball change
Maria Thomas on YouTube said Keough you
should have been in the finale there we
go
he literally just toast ready sell
yes well I mean I'm assuming we'll see
you guys both back next season in the
fall I hope so okay so we hope so is
that a discussion every time or you how
does that work it's it's like you know
the people it's all about casting sure
yeah so if they cast you with the if
they can cast you with the right
celebrity then Your Honor we have sasha
was gone for a minute but then singing
backward times that season so awesome
yeah I know you and Jenny we're the two
tallest pros ever maybe together come on
well we are winding down here but um I
know I know we have to I know well I
still have questions for you guys ain't
no one room okay okay um what about an
all-star season crystal is asking if
they would do another all-star season
who would you like to see what that is
really good I have a few that I would
like to go for it nor money for sure
zendaya for sure yes and she's great but
and bindhi was like unstoppable
something yes okay any guys you can
think of James Hinchcliffe Oh Rashad
Rashad for sure mm-hmm I think it would
be honest with you like alphonsine
Dancing with the Stars and like all the
athletes guy I get guy at kids I think
Rashad was done was the only guy from
personally for me that he's a good
dancer I mean I thought of funds it was
a really good answer and yep I'm saying
I can try that beauty to go you know I
mean like the thing with Josh is I have
a lot of time to progress yeah he was
good he had great yeah but Rashad had
ten weeks to get to but even him the
first week though he had the same about
you know
good he's looking good well we did see a
lot of improvement I mean even tanya was
talking about you know she got so fit
being on the show and seeing that number
last night I felt like you saw her
journey I also wanted to ask you guys
because it was kind of nice to see when
Adam was here we talked to him about
Tommy a little bit he had a few things
to say and then last night during the
credits we saw them hugging he was
telling her great job how did Adam and
Tanya's relationship end up you know I
think everyone's relationship was really
supportive I don't know what he said
here but did you read the tabloids I was
like no I don't cut Anya well I we loved
watching her but she had come from a
very controversial background who she is
an American history and everything that
she went through so I think that was
just he was just speaking to that to how
she's known in the skating world and we
saw them hugging each other the skating
world is its own the world didn't yes I
I know they have their you know she is
banned so they have their well now they
have their world yeah but I think in the
in the ballroom everyone was so
supportive
yeah and I mean you can feel the love
and the energy in there and it was
awesome dancing is so different like
it's it's it's it's a wall that like we
all come together like yeah I think it's
so it's way different issue but I think
all the celebrities and the athletes
they're really struggling together you
know it's not easy for anyone
mm-hmm even for a demur right it wasn't
easy for them because they're not
ballroom dancers yeah they figure
skating but you know so what do you guys
do after finale do you go out and have
the after-party what did everybody do
last night
why are you so tired this morning I was
rehearsing yes yes yes we have to the
show we had a party this is actually the
first rap party I've ever been to cuz I
usually go to GMA so I got a GMA off it
was fun it was fun you know
a lot of people don't know our crew is
so funny
yeah and they don't get enough
recognition you know they literally put
up the set like and those set pieces are
clearly it is so quickly
you know our sorry my voice from all the
screaming at the after training we had
Cinderella's carriage and it was huge
right so like just to move that in and
they get three minutes they got a
commercial break up with so everybody
let's lose the wrap party everyone comes
together together the executive
producers you know the field producers
are okay who had the most cocktails at
the wrap party I don't know I didn't
drink yeah I had water sparkling water
did Tania and Adam have a hug and a chat
at the rapper oh they went to Tanja well
they went to Sonya was the Catania was
there for a few minutes you're stopping
by I hope I came ok who dances the most
at the wrap party even though you've
Amin did you know I think no we're done
like let me tell you something no don't
understand we are really good at dancing
on the floor yeah I say so myself but
when we go to a club you know I don't
know myself I've also my friends are
like when we go either like you know why
don't you dance it like when we go out
and I was here and she said she's like
when I go to weddings aren't even really
- I'm just like yeah I want to end this
with something fun Larry brought this up
and we were going to Keough you are real
royalty this is a real Prince you guys
so Keough
tell us what you saw we can the Royal
Wedding yeah that's a little bit of it
but it's a little bit I got home after
like camera blocking and I saw my coffin
watching it I was like yep are you
looking - you think you're gonna get
that beautiful will you have a very
regal awesome hold on not that extreme
but will it be some lighting we back
home we have like three days of avoiding
will David Beckham be there that's what
I want to you over there you will be
there I'm gonna fly you home
because you are Prince of of in like in
a small town in Johannesburg okay so you
will have a three day wedding yeah so
what happens is we have a wedding but
like in my culture first and then we
have a wedding at her culture and then a
white wedding so we do three days yeah
okay and what did you think of the
wedding dress the style I mean is that
what everyone talks right I think it was
good but it was not yeah it wasn't like
tied you know what do you think are the
same I saw on social media I saw this
clip a lot when he was like you're so
beautiful it was really cute fairytale
moment you had the Disney carriage they
had a carriage - yeah
you're a prince basically alright guys
well thank you so much for being here
with us again everybody wanted you two
to be in the finale so we'll see you in
you know what I gotta say I'm gonna
throw this out there I'm excited to see
does not to be YouTube but maybe a
same-sex really Dancing with the Stars
oh you know they did that it was in
Manila and Jody and Peeta yeah that
would be exciting you know I know you
know we did the all athletes season I
mean are there any other ways you guys
can think of that you'd like to see the
show switch it up or try something new
or different
I mean I feel like you know what I don't
think they're usually so good because it
has so much diversity it has singers as
actors and as athletes it has it has
everything yeah I wanna sure should do
like all like second places of every
season I'm also going to say fans the
answer the fans Oh interesting
no maybe like like a four week kind of
special okay I like that our Dancing
with the Stars runner-up like all the
runner-ups get a second shot okay great
well we figured out the next couple
years Alan Burstyn and keel what's up a
thank you so much for joining us guys
make sure to follow these two on social
media and of course watch Dancing with
the Stars check them out on tour and
watch ET tonight because our own Cameron
Mathison was backstage on the red carpet
getting all the scoop right after the
show thanks everybody for watching
all season long and we'll see you next
time thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]